MANISH BHARGAVA: OK.
Let's get started.
I'm Manish Bhargava,
product manager for
internationalization and
localization efforts at Google.
And we have Andrew
Warren, a product
manager in the same team.
He'll help us with the awesome
demos that we have
lined up for you.
So today, we are going to talk
about developing for global
audience for every web user,
for every smartphone user.
Let's start by me asking
you a few questions.
How many of you here speak
more than one language?
Great.
How many of you here are
Chrome developers?
How many of you are Android
developers?
OK.
Looking at the audience, we'll
focus more on the Android
developer perspective.
And then, how many of you have
your app or product localized
in more than one language?
More than five?
More than 10?
More than 20?
More than 40?
Great.
You are definitely ahead
of the pack.
So let's talk a little
bit about what we're
going to talk today.
We'll start by talking
about developing
for a global audience.
Is it worth it?
What does it entail?
How do I go about doing it?
And then once I've done it,
how do I get the global
customers that I intend
to reach?
In our journey of the what,
[INAUDIBLE], why and how, we
will essentially also do an
in-depth look at various
internationalization and
localization tools
available to you.
So the very first question is
is it worth developing for a
global audience?
To answer that question, let's
first look at what is needed
to have a successful business.
You need users and
a lot of them.
And you need revenue,
and probably, a
lot of that as well.
But the question is where
are these users located?
How do we get to them?
So let's quickly do
a quick demo.
Here, we have the--
OK, full screen.
So what we're looking at is
a gapminder.org chart.
We are looking at internet users
in terms of how internet
users have changed over time.
We'll do a time travel starting
from 1990 onwards.
The size of the bubble
represents the number of
internet users.
So the bigger the size, more
internet users in that region.
So let's start in 1990.
Only noticeable dots at this
point are US and Japan.
And even within that scenario,
it's mostly coming from
universities, I believe.
So now, let's fast
forward to 2000.
Notice here.
In addition to US and Japan, we
now also have some of the
European languages show up.
Now let's fast forward
from 2000 to 2010.
And during this phase,
I would like you to
focus on two aspects.
One is the explosive growth in
terms of internet users in the
BRIC countries--
Brazil, Russia, India,
and China.
And especially, look at
the last five years.
So let's run through that
starting from 2000 And notice
how it changed.
Let me, again, run it from 2005
again just to highlight
the difference.
So based on the chart, what is
the percentage of internet
users that do not use English
as a native language?
That is correct.
26% use English as their
native language.
Now let's look at another
similar chart.
This time, we are looking at
cellphone users instead of
internet users.
And the size of the bubbles
would represent number of cell
phone users over time.
Let's do a time travel starting
from 1980 to the
current time.
So let's first fast forward
from 1980 to 2000.
Notice the penetration or the
number of cell phone users is
nearly very similar to what we
saw in internet users with US,
Japan, and some of the European
countries having
enough presence.
Now, let's do the same
from 2000 to 2010.
What we see is very similar
phenomenon that we saw in the
number of internet users.
The number of cell phone users
have grown in explosive
numbers during the
last five years,
especially in the BRIC countries.
OK.
So clearly based on what we
have seen, you can nearly
triple the number of users by
essentially developing for the
global audience.
And when you triple the number
of users, you thereby increase
your revenue as well.
So let's look at the
revenue numbers a
little bit more carefully.
So we'll talk about the Android
opportunity available
to you from a global
perspective.
Remember the keynote speech
on Wednesday?
We talked about, and we showed
on the world heat map the
explosive growth in terms of
Android activations over the
last few years, especially
outside United States.
The same is true for the
app installs as well.
And we believe your app should
now take advantage of this
huge opportunity.
And we have the right
infrastructure in place for
you to do that.
So starting with Apps
availability, the free Apps
are available in
190 languages--
190 countries.
And 132 of these countries
have access to the
paid apps as well.
Globally, 92% of all Google
Play users have
access to paid apps.
And not surprising, 67% of all
Google Play revenue comes from
outside United States.
We have revenue infrastructure
in place.
Carrier billing is available in
seven key countries and is
expanding rapidly.
Why is that important?
Because 73% of all Google Play
app purchases happens using
carrier billing when
it is available.
And you also have access to all
monetization methods that
include the in-app billing, paid
apps, subscription, as
well as ad funded as well.
Last but not least, we have now
the dev infrastructure in
place with the Wednesday
announcement
of the new Dev Console.
You can now localize your
listing in 22 languages as
well as tweak your international
offerings based
on slicing and dicing on
country and language
dimensions available
on the analytics
section of the Dev Console.
So clearly, there's
a huge opportunity
which cannot be ignored.
But the next question is,
what does it entail?
How do I make use of
this opportunity?
What you need to do to make this
happen, the two things
that you need are
internationalization and
localization.
Internationalization--
i18n, I followed by 18
characters and N. And
localization--
L followed by 10 characters
and N.
What does internationalization
mean?
It essentially means designing
and coding to enable support
for languages, countries, and
cultural differences.
It includes things like
extracting your strings for
localization, presenting date,
time, currency, number formats
in the local relevant form,
sorting in language specific
ways, able to work on or process
user input in the
given language.
It also means handling
bi-directional display in
Middle Eastern languages,
handling diacritics for
central European languages,
handling double byte
characters for East
Asian languages.
And what is localization?
Localization is the process of
adapting the look and feel of
your app for languages,
regions, and culture.
What does it entail?
Essentially, it includes things
like translation, local
defaults, and custom features.
Let's take an example.
So what you're looking at is
Google Sites, specifically the
image upload menu.
What is wrong here?
And again, I've given you
a hint right there with
highlighting the region.
Anyone knows Arabic here?
What's wrong?
Yes.
Notice how in English, we have
the size of the image-- small,
medium, or large--
where translated in Arabic, it
actually became Saturday,
medium, and then large.
Why?
What happened?
Well, two aspects.
When this was sent for
translation, the small,
medium, and large were sent as
separate words and with no
description being provided.
And the second, when the
translator got this for
translation, they had little
context of where these were
coming from.
So again, S became Sat,
which essentially was
translated as Saturday.
Let's take few more examples.
Here, what you're looking at
is Google Earth mobile app.
And we are focused in
the Zurich view.
Anybody from Zurich here?
Can you tell us what is wrong?
Notice how the two places, the
names of the two places have
been garbled.
The non-ASCII characters have
been removed, specifically the
u with the umlaut is not being
displayed correctly.
This is clearly an example of
an internationalization, or
i18n, issue where the text has
not been rendered correctly.
When we talked to the engineers
and tried to find
out what happened, the real
issue was that third party
JSON library was being
leveraged to do
deserialization of
the JSON file.
And that did not handle the
escaping characters in
meaningful ways.
So here was an example of
internationalization.
Let's look at another
example of--
here, we are talking about
Google Maps in Swedish.
And on the on the left-hand
side, you also see the
corresponding English
version as well.
I'll tell you a little bit more
background on this one.
A phenomenon that we saw was
in Sweden, specifically
driving direction functionality,
we were seeing
about 10% to 15% less usage of
that functionality compared to
nearby places, compared to all
our average worldwide.
And we wanted to understand
what is happening.
So we put an engineer in
Mountain View for about a week
to try to find what
is happening.
This person essentially, very
smart engineer, went through
all the algorithms that we're
using for driving directions
and how we are pulling them.
They looked at all our data
sources in terms local data
and displaying the
street names and
all of those correctly.
And it turned out, yes, all of
that was being done correctly.
Anyone know Swedish here?
Can you tell what might
have been wrong?
And the problem was the Get
Direction as in English was
translated as Instructions
in Swedish.
And again, as a Google Map user,
when I see instruction,
I would not really think of
getting driving directions
based on seeing that
instruction.
And that really what happened.
When we changed that to really
mean get direction in Swedish,
we suddenly saw a sudden jump in
terms of the usage for the
functionality.
And then, it became on par
with other regions in the
world as well.
So what we want to highlight
from these examples is that
the user experience is impacted
in a big way by how
you do internationalization
and localization
implementation.
So we have talked about what
i18n is, what localization is.
But the next question is
what do I need to do?
What does it really
mean for me?
So let's talk a little bit about
a globalized application
architecture or the design in
terms of how you will design
your application in meaningful
ways to make it happen.
First is your application or
your common code base.
And that would essentially be
common across all countries.
It would contain the code
of your functionality.
And this would be language
neutral.
This is where all your
key algorithms and
everything would go.
The next set, which you would
essentially separate out in
meaningful ways, is the
globalization services.
Anything that is
language-dependent, so it
could be things like handling
of date, time, currencies,
displaying them correctly,
extraction, anything which is
language-dependent would
essentially fall under here.
And you would essentially use
different libraries to handle
them effectively.
The next set is the
locale data.
So essentially, it's important
to separate localizable
resources from your
main code base.
So examples of localizable
resources would be text,
images, and so on.
So notice here how the English,
Japanese, and French
version are all separated out?
So if you were to use, for
example, Java, you would
essentially use the resource
bundles to handle these
language sources.
And having those separated
makes it easy for
localization as well.
And then, finally, is the
plug-in, which essentially,
think of that as a
custom feature
for your local markets.
Why is that important?
It really brings the wow
factor for your app.
Think of like we had the
transit app in German.
And when we introduced German
train schedules, that really
made people feel, wow, this
app has been made for me
rather than something which will
just ported over from US
with some cosmetic changes.
Another example is we introduced
cricket scores on
Google News in India.
When we did that on the days
when the cricket match was on,
we saw about 8% to 10% increase
in daily traffic.
Why?
People were able to
essentially-- again, cricket
and Bollywood are pretty
popular in India.
And people would essentially
come and see those scores on
Google News when the game
was on those days.
So here is the complete
picture of
internationalization.
It is how you would typically
do your internationalization
from a design perspective and
how you would have your
different parts of your code
base separated out in
meaningful ways so that you can
essentially then extend in
meaningful ways and make your
code base ready for
localization.
Now, let's look at some of the
available tools that will help
you to make this happen.
Here are some tools that
are listed for
internationalization.
Some of these tools, we are
actively working on.
Some of these tools, we actively
contribute to.
But in either of those
scenarios, these are the exact
same tools that we use
at Google for our
internationalization as well.
So the first is the
ICU, International
Component for Unicode.
Think of that as a hidden
gold mine for you.
It really provides you the right
libraries in various
programming languages--
C/C++, Java--
for you to handle Unicode
and globalization
in meaningful ways.
So you can handle things like
date, time, currency,
formatting, and much more
using this library.
The next library is the
libphonenumber library.
It essentially handles
the international
phone numbers for you.
It essentially incorporates all
world regions, so things
like area code, country
codes, and all of
the intricacies involved.
It essentially encapsulates all
of that and gives you a
simple interface by which you
can essentially do parsing,
formatting, storing, and
validating of phone numbers
across any region
in the world.
And again, pretty powerful
in respect to that.
In terms of JavaScript, the
Google Web Toolkit and closure
tools provide
internationalization support
for JavaScript.
We're extending that support
using the ECMAScript standard
process for that as well.
For input, research has clearly
showed that users tend
to use an app more if they're
able to input
in their own language.
And that's where Google Input
Tools, a Chrome extension
comes into play.
It is a tool that allows users
to input in 80 plus languages
on any text box on
any web page.
Why don't we first look at a
quick introductory video?
And then, Andrew will do a quick
demo of that as well.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-There's this word in Chinese,
Xiang, that kind of means
smells good.
It could describe flower,
food, really anything.
But it's always a positive
description for things.
It's hard to translate into
something other than Mandarin.
-We have this word in Fiji-Hindi
called Talanoa.
Really, it is the feeling that
you get late on a Friday night
surrounded by your friends
shooting the breeze.
But it's not quite that.
It's a sort of warmer and
friendlier version of small
talk, just about everything that
you could think of off
the top of your head.
-There's this Greek word,
Meraki, that means to really
put your soul, put your entire
being into what you're doing,
whether it's your hobby,
or it's your work.
You're doing it with love
for what you're doing.
But it's one of those cultural
things that I've never been
able to come up with
a good translation.
Meraki, with passion,
with love.
[END VIDEO PLAYBACK]
MANISH BHARGAVA: Great.
Andrew, why don't you give us
a quick demo of lesson.
ANDREW WARREN: Certainly.
So as Manish was mentioning
earlier, the majority of web
users online, and the majority
of users of cell phones, and
the majority of pretty much
all of Google's users and
internet users are not from
English-speaking countries and
don't speak English natively.
What's more, and much more
important, the majority of
users coming online at this
point, the majority of users
who are just beginning to use
these technologies are not
native English speakers, and in
most cases, are not English
speakers at all.
So one of the things that we're
trying to do at Google
is make it easier for these new
users to actively engage
online to create content, to
communicate with people in
their own languages.
And so one of the ways that
we're doing that is this
project called Input Tools,
which is a project to make it
easy to enter text in whatever
language you'd like to.
So I'll be giving a brief
demonstration of the Chrome
extension that we've recently
put out for this purpose.
All a user needs to do after
installing the Chrome
extension is choose the
languages that he or she might
want to type in.
So in this case, I'll add some
Chinese input methods and some
Hindi input methods.
And then, that's
pretty much it.
From there, If the user wants to
enter text in one of those
languages or in a language that
they don't have the right
keyboard for, don't have the
right input tools for on their
computer, all they need to do is
enable the Chrome extension
and tell it which language
they'd like to type in.
And from there, we use server
side dictionaries and language
models to determine what words
they're looking for and what
words they might want to type.
So we have this available for
IMEs for Chinese and Japanese,
which includes the keyboard
shortcuts that Chinese and
Japanese users are probably
familiar with already from
clients site IMEs.
We have a number of
transliteration tools for
speakers of Indic languages
and others.
And then, we also have a number
of virtual keyboards
which we offer which can both
be used to literally type
using the mouse, or which can
be used just as a keyboard
mapping if the users already
familiar with that keyword but
doesn't have it available where
they are at the moment.
So this is something that we
have available for over 80
different languages already in
the Chrome extension for
online users and are also
working to bring to other
platforms as well.
So we have all of the 20 plus
transliteration languages and
Chinese and Japanese available
on Windows.
And then, we also brought
Chinese, Japanese Korean, and
a number of other languages to
Android and are continuing to
build out the number of
languages we support so that
more users can create content.
More users can communicate with
one another in whatever
language they like to.
So, post demo, there's
a couple of important
implications of this
for developers as
well for input tools.
The first of these is that you
never know what tools people
might be using to enter text
into your website or into your
application.
So specifically, they
may be using
this Input Tools extension.
They may be using a client
site IME of some kind.
Or they may be using other
accessibility tools, like
Chrome Box, to read what's on
the screen, or what's in a
text box, or know where
a text box is.
And so it's very important
that when you build
applications, particularly web
applications but also Android
applications, that you're using
standard components and
standard pieces of HTML and
don't do anything terribly
fancy with input boxes, with
editable DIVs, so that these
tools will work for users not
just within the US and Europe,
but also for users
around the world.
The second key takeaway for
developers is that you don't
really know what types of
content are coming into your
application or where they're
coming from.
So you may be getting all types
of content, in all kinds
of languages, in all kinds of
encodings, where you may not
have designed it for that.
So it's important for
applications to be built from
the ground up supporting Unicode
and assuming Unicode
is coming into the application
and processing all of the
strings in any other aspects of
what the application does
assuming Unicode
and in Unicode.
So from the developers'
perspective, there's a lot of
other things that need to go
into an application to ensure
that technologies like
these work for
users around the world.
MANISH BHARGAVA: Great.
Thank you, Andrew.
So up to this point,
we have looked at
internationalization, what it
entails, what does the global
design look like, global
architecture looks like.
And then, we have also
looked at some other
internationalization tools.
Now, let's do the same
for localization.
First of all, here are the five
points that you would
need to do for localization
irrespective of what you're
localizing.
So it could be your
Android apps.
It could be your Chrome maps.
It could be a website.
It could be your static
files documents.
First of all, you need
to determine your
target language set.
And again, that's a very
important decision
that needs to happen.
And again, that may change
over time as well.
We will talk about some of the
considerations for that in our
next slide.
Second is separating localizable
resources from
your source code.
And again, we saw on the global
architecture design,
that was essentially the
third set of boxes.
And that is very critical for
you to essentially have a good
localized experience.
You don't own hard-coded strings
in your application to
show up, especially when
people are accessing in
different languages.
The third aspect is test
your application for
localizability issues.
How do you know whether it's
ready for actual localization?
You would essentially at the
point when you are ready for
translation, you should not
require any re-engineering or
code changes.
In that case, we have taken
care of most of the
localizability issues.
And so the localization tools
are really your friend here at
this point for that.
If those tools can help you
find problems like text
swirling, hard-coded strings,
not handling accented
characters, even before you
actually do the localization.
And again, we would highly
encourage you to use that
phase in terms of your
pseudolocalization.
The fourth is you will choose
a localization vendor.
And either them or you will
choose the localization tool
that you use.
Important consideration for
localization tools are, it
should have advanced
technologies like translation
memory, glossary, and so on.
As we've talked in the previous
slide, let's talk a
little bit more about the key
considerations that you have
when deciding which locale, a
combination of your country
and location, you would like
to have your app or your
product available in.
Broadly, the considerations
could be
divided into two types.
One is the key matrix based
on various key metrics.
And again, there could
be a variety of them.
And the second is based on
the effort required for
implementation of these.
So let's talk more about
the key metrics.
So again, there could be a
variety of different key
metrics that you could base your
decision in terms which
countries or which languages
to go after.
You could essentially
decide based on top
languages used on the web.
You could essentially base it on
top countries by cell phone
usage, top countries by
paid app installed.
You could essentially go by
what my competitor offers.
If competitor is localized in 15
languages, you might do the
same as well.
And then, finally, there
could be some
app-specific metric as well.
So for example, if you are a
game developer, you might want
to go by the top countries
by paid game downloads.
So let's say we picked one.
We go by top languages
used on the web.
And we localize in
10 languages.
So you essentially pick the
top 10 languages on the
internet and say, OK, I will
localize in those.
Question for the audience?
What is the percentage of users
you can cover if you
essentially do that?
You would essentially localize
your app in top 10 languages.
What percentage of internet
users would you cover?
Yes.
It is 82%.
Absolutely right.
You essentially-- and again,
let's see a little bit more
details here.
So this is the breakdown of the
top 10 languages and then
the remaining set.
So notice English
is about 26%.
Chinese is pretty close, 24%.
And then, you can see
the remaining ones.
After the top 10, which is about
82%, the rest of the
languages constitute
about 17.8%.
So let's look a little bit
more carefully here.
If you pick the top 5, you
include Chinese in here.
If you include the top 10, you
also include Arabic here.
These are languages that require
special handling for
doing localization and
internationalization correctly
for these languages.
So you might want to do some
cherry picking in terms of
which languages you want to
localize your app into based
on where you are.
And that's a good segue into our
second aspect in terms of
effort required for implementing
those languages.
So there's a natural grouping
of languages.
So let's say your app currently
is in English.
Now, what is the next set
of languages that
you could go after?
The next set, which adds a
little bit of complexity but
not that much is the Latin
script languages.
These are languages which
include FIGS--
French, Italian German,
Spanish--
Indonesian, Romanian,
Vietnamese, and so on.
There are three things that this
set of languages add in
terms of complexity
for your app.
First is the ability to handle
the language preference.
So users should be able to
choose from a dropdown, so a
language picker, and say OK,
I want now my app to be in
German, Spanish, and so on.
The second is the ability
to search in those
languages in your app.
And for that, you need
language detection
mechanism as well.
So with those, you can pretty
much try and target the Latin
script languages.
You will probably need some
bit of testing as well.
The next set of languages that
you can target are non-Latin,
European languages.
These would include languages
like Russian, Ukrainian,
Serbian, and Greek.
In addition to what we described
for Latin script
languages, there are added
complexities in terms of
transliteration is important
for these languages.
Plus for languages
like Serbian, the
interchangeability between the
Latin script keyboards and the
Cyrillic keyboards becomes
an important aspect
to consider as well.
The next set of languages
are the CJK--
the Chinese, Japanese
and Korean.
Here, the complexities first
is the font size.
You need to take care of that
because characters typically
tend to be bigger in size.
The second is the display
mechanism might change.
So some of these languages are
displayed vertically as well.
And the third aspect is input.
So input method iterators become
an important aspect.
Why?
Because just the enormous
number of
characters in these languages.
The next set of languages are
the South and Southeast Asian
languages, specifically
Thai and Hindi.
They are typical because
you need to handle
the contextual display.
Characters in these languages
essentially change based on
the context.
And the second important
aspect is the size
segmentation.
So in Thai, where the words
are not separated by wide
space, you need to take care of,
especially from a search
perspective, how the
segmentation is done correctly.
And the last of languages are
the bi-directional languages,
which include Arabic, Hebrew,
Persian, Urdu.
And these are really the most
challenging languages from
engineering perspective.
Why are these called
bi-directional languages?
Mainly because the text flows
from right to left and the
numbers go from left to right.
Special attention is needed
for the user interface,
especially in those languages.
Now, let's look at some of the
available tools for each of
these kind of applications, so
Android apps, Chrome web store
apps, your website, and your
static file and docs as well.
So let's take them one by one.
So first is localization
of your Android apps.
As we mentioned earlier as well,
it is important for you
to have a localization
strategy.
By that, we mean you need to
know which languages and which
countries you are going to
localize your app into, which
is your default set of language
and country, and
finally, what happens when
somebody accesses your app in
a locale in which you are
not localizing into.
So here are the three
things where that
happened in that scenario.
First, as I said, you create
your resource sets for each of
the locale that you
want to go in.
At run time, the resource
set is matching the
device, locale is loaded.
And if locale specific resources
are not available,
Android falls back
to the defaults.
Let's talk a little bit more
about some of the technical
details here.
So strings.xml file contains
your translated strings.
So under res/values, that's
where your strings.xml in that
directory would contain the
default translations.
So let's say if you were to
translate in French and
Arabic, you would also have
directories called
res/values-fr and res/values-ar
respectively.
And strings.xml within those
directories would contain the
translated strings for French
and Arabic as well.
And let's say you had other
resources as well that needed
to be translated.
So graphics, for example, you
would have res/drawable-ja for
handling the graphics in
Japanese, for example.
So here's the typical Android
localization process.
You essentially have
three steps here--
the planning and design phase,
the actual translation, and
then, finally, testing
and publishing.
Right at the very bottom, you
see the link to the guide for
localization in
developers.android.com.
In that, you will find
essentially all details for
each of the steps what
you need to do there.
What I would highly encourage
for everyone to do here, if
you haven't done that already,
is to take the Hello L10
example, so Hello Localization
example, similar to the Hello
world example when you
try a new language.
You would list in a very simple
way all the steps that
you need to do to
have your first
localized version of that.
And it's a very simple app, just
has few phases, and the
map for that country
and displays that.
So again, if you haven't done
this, I would highly encourage
you to try this, the
Hello L10n example.
And again, you will find that
in localization guide at
developers.android.com.
So let's look at localization of
the Chrome web store apps.
One important aspect here is
that you can do your listing
in 43 locales from the Chrome
dashboard, developer dashboard.
And the second, depending on
whether you have an extension,
or packaged app, or hosted app,
your app localization
mechanism would be different.
So let's look a little bit
more at the extension and
packaged app where you have more
control over the files
right in your dashboard.
From a technical perspective,
your messages.joson will
contain the translations.
You will define your default
locale in your
manifest or JSON file.
And you would essentially have
your different translations in
_locale directories.
So for example, again, taking
the same example, if you are
French and Arabic, you would
essentially have _locale/fr.
And then, within that,
you will have the
message or JSON file.
And same form, _locale/ar/json
file to contain the Arabic
translations as well.
In terms of localization
process, it is again very
similar to what we described
in the Android process as
well-- the planning and design
phase, the translation phase,
and then the testing and
publishing phase.
One important distinction is
that you essentially provide
the localized description and
screenshots and the time when
you're uploading for each
language at one time.
So again, the reference
there at the bottom,
code.google.com/
chrome/extensions/i18n.html,
you will find all the details
about the Chrome web store
localization as well.
Now, let's talk about localizing
your website.
With Google Website Translator,
you can instantly
translate your website into
60 plus languages.
Sounds interesting.
Want to find out more?
Let's look at a video.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-The Website Translator plug-in
powered by Google
Translate allows you to quickly
and easily make your
website or blog instantly
available in 60 plus languages.
Just add the plug-in code
snippet to your page, where
you'd like to language
selector to appear.
And whenever an international
user visits your page, they
can select their language in
the dropdown, and your page
will be instantly translated
into the language.
While the quality of translation
from Google
Translate is quite good, it's
not always perfect.
For these situations, the
Website Translator plug-in
allows you to publish and
improve the translation.
After you translate the page,
just hover over the translated
sentence you'd like to improve
and enter the correction in
the pop-up.
Your correction will now be
used whenever someone
translate your page.
Users visiting your site can
also suggest translations
using the same process.
However, these suggestions
won't be
used until you approve.
You can manage these suggestions
in the Website
Translator's web management
interface.
Just select and improve the
suggestion, and it will be
used whenever someone translates
your page.
Add the Website Translator
plug-in into your website now
and make your website
globally accessible.
[END VIDEO PLAYBACK]
MANISH BHARGAVA: This was Jeff
Chin, again on our team, who
works on the Google Website
Translator.
So again, as was described in
the video, you can instantly
translate in 60 plus
languages.
But what we launched about a
month back is very powerful.
We're not just using the
machine translation.
You can now customize and
improve your website
translation by manually going
in and correcting
what might be wrong.
In addition, you can also
collect and use the
translation selections from
your users as well.
And again, you can invite
editors to manage your
translations.
And that way, you essentially,
again, make your website
instantly available for a
lot of users worldwide.
So we already did that.
Let's now look at localization
of your documents,
localization of your
static files.
You could essentially use Google
Translation Toolkit,
GTT, for doing that.
What is GTT?
GTT is Google's localization
platform for human
translators.
They can essentially use this
to do translation faster and
more correctly.
You edit by technologies
like Google Translate.
It essentially supports a wide
variety of document types.
To name a few, you essentially
get your Word documents, your
Open Office files, your rich
text file formats, your HTML
text files, PO flies, Android
resources, Chrome extensions,
Edward campaign, Wikipedia
articles.
So again, a slew of stuff that
you can essentially localize
using the tool.
It supports more than
300 standard
source and target languages.
And it has a simple what
you see is what
you get wizard editor.
And the best part of all of
this, it's essentially a
totally free tool.
So you can essentially leverage
that for your
translations as well.
We would also like to talk a
little bit more about things
that are in works.
Given what you have heard over
the last two years, Android
apps and Chrome apps are a very
important part of our ecosystem.
And given that, we want to
now optimize on our app
localization platform,
especially for Android and
Chrome apps.
We also would like to--
essentially working on
optimizing our YouTube caption
localization process as well.
With respect to the apps'
localization platform, Andrew,
why don't you give us a
sneak peek into that?
ANDREW WARREN: Sure.
So as Manish mentioned, we're
working on a new form of the
Google translation toolkit that
is focused on application
translation and localization.
So in particular, the main point
of this tool is to make
it so that developers don't
really need to understand what
goes on behind the scenes for
translator and all of the
tools that they need to use to
properly localize something.
And a translator doesn't need to
understand what's going on
behind the scenes of an
application and need to
understand the structure of the
application and where the
files sit in the application,
all of that information.
So we're trying to make it
as easy as possible for
developers and for translators
to do their job without
needing to understand each
other's roles as much.
So given that, all the developer
needs to do upon
coming to the system is add the
resource files from their
application, from whatever
framework they've been using.
So we support Java properties
files, Ruby on Rails YAML
files, a number of other file
formats from popular
frameworks, and are continuing
to add more
files as we go along.
And then, choose the languages
that the developer wants their
app to be translated into.
So in this case, we've chosen
Arabic, Chinese,
Spanish, and Thai.
And then, the last step from a
developer's perspective is to
add collaborators
to that project.
So decide who you want to come
help you translate this.
It could be friends or family
who speak other languages and
have offered to help
translate.
It could be community members
or members of your user base
who offered to help
translate your
application to their language.
Or it could be professional
translators who you decided to
hire to come in and translate
your application in your first
international launch to
five languages or
something of that nature.
So after adding collaborators
and the translators, the
developer's job is effectively
done here.
They don't need to understand
what happens after that point.
But if you want to, you can go
into that part of the process.
And we'll show you a little
bit of what that
looks like as well.
So when a translator gets an
invitation to come in and work
on a translation project for
any of the apps that
developers might upload here,
what they'll see is the actual
translation interface where we
basically laid out all of the
messages that need to be
translated and kind of
abstracted away all of the
different files those came
from, where they sit
in the application.
And the translator can just go
ahead and enter translations
as they go along.
A few other features that make
this a little bit more
convenient is we've also
abstracted away the individual
placeholder support
for each language.
So a translator can use
placeholders without needing
to understand how the
programming language that was
used actually implements
placeholders.
And we just go ahead when the
developer comes back to export
the file and replace it with
the placeholders that that
language is using.
Another thing that's convenient,
particularly for
application translation, is the
suggestions feature, which
allows us to offer suggestions
both from Google Translate,
but also from previous
translations within that
application or within
that project.
So if you have a number of
translators coming in, and the
word photos has been translated
somewhere earlier
on, but you now have a new
phrase in the application,
view my photos, then that
translator will get a preview,
a suggestion, of what word to
use there so that you maintain
a consistent translation
throughout the entire project.
The most important thing that
we found when looking at why
applications are very different
from static files
and from other types of content
that you might want to
localize is that applications
have very short UI strings.
And so it's very difficult
to get a sense of what an
individual string or message
might mean for a translator,
which leads to issues like
Manish described before.
Small, medium, and
large becomes
Saturday, medium, and large.
These sorts of things stem
from translators not
understanding what a message
is supposed to be in the
actual application.
So what we worked hard to do
is make sure that we give
developers the ability to
capture very easily the
context of their application
and to capture snapshots so
that the translator can
translate in context exactly
what the message means and can
see in real-time how that
impacts what the message
looks like in the UI.
A couple of other very
convenient aspects of this
that help the localization
process significantly is that
the developer can come through
after the fact and take a look
at all messages that have or
haven't been translated and
get a sense of everything looks
fine in Chinese except
there's this English word over
here that's still in English.
So clearly I missed something
when I was putting things into
my resource bundles.
The other thing that's somewhat
nice about this is a
developer can come back to this
UI if they want to after
the translation is complete and
can see the impact that
the translation has on the UI.
Because the process we used to
capture the messages from the
application not only captures
the HTML and the actual
snapshot, but it also
captures the CSS.
So we actually have the
style information.
And you can see in real-time
what happens when a particular
message breaks the UI.
In this case, a very long
message might push some of
these items onto the next line
which would break the UI and
break the CSS.
So the developer can get a sense
of where problems are in
their interface and can fix
those problems before
redeploying the app
in new languages.
So this is something that we're
continuing to work on
and are looking forward to
making available publicly in
the near future.
MANISH BHARGAVA: Great.
That was great, especially
the screenshot part.
Thank you, Andrew.
OK.
So we are at the point where
we have looked at
globalization and getting your
app for a global audience
makes lot of sense.
We also looked at what it
entails and how do we achieve
that in terms of both
internationalization and
localization.
We looked at available tools.
Now, let's say you have
done all of that.
You have now a localized app.
What's next?
The natural question is how
do I get my app now
to the right audience?
So how do I find the customers,
and do the global
customers find me?
So listed here are some of the
practical tips for you to
market your app, especially
where is Google marketplaces,
including Chrome web store,
including Google Play for
Android app as well.
So first and foremost, if you
do nothing else, you should
localize your marketplace
metadata
into different languages.
That by itself significantly
boosts your app's ranking in
the marketplace, especially
for that locale.
So that's the first
and foremost part.
The second is maximize your
search potential.
Why is that important?
Because search accounts for
about 2/3 of all installs and
sales on Google Play.
How do you do that?
How do you maximize your
search potential?
Think of the keywords.
Think of the keywords that
somebody would search for when
your app should show up and
include those in your title,
in your description.
Both of these fields are
indexed from a search
perspective.
And once you have included
those keywords in the
respective locales as well, the
findability of your app
increases multi-folds in terms
of a search perspective.
One key insight in terms of,
again, ranking of your app in
these locale, there are
three main factors
that go into that.
One is high number
of installs.
The second is low number
of uninstalls.
And the third is long
term usage.
So how many users are using
your app over a
long period of time?
So for that, the steady effort
on your part for
internationalization and
localization becomes a very
key factor here.
So think of your investment in
terms of advertising campaign
and so on over a period of time
rather than just be in
short bursts.
And lastly, localize
your app listing.
Localize your app screenshots.
If your apps screenshot reflect
the actual user
experience, the number of
the installs go higher.
And more importantly, number
of uninstalls go lower.
And that again helps in terms of
findability of your app on
various marketplaces.
So take home message.
Important thing to
note here is--
like again, we covered a
lot of details here.
If you forget most of the stuff,
please remember these
four things.
First is it is never
too late to start.
So if you haven't done that, you
still have your app only
in English or one of the
languages, get started now.
Get started today.
Opportunity, as we have showed
in the initial slide,
opportunity is just too
big for you to ignore.
So focus on that.
The third is it is relatively
very simple to get started.
And again, it will not get you
in the perfect state right
away, but you will get there.
So things like just remove
any hard-coded string.
Externalize them.
Make them as resource bundles
and send them for translation.
Use a few libraries so that
you do the number handling
date format, currency formats,
et cetera, correctly.
And then, get your friend, get
your family to come and help
you translate in just
one language.
So you can essentially take all
your strings and say, OK,
we're good to go.
Let's essentially use
these and just
do it for one language.
It will not be perfect
as I said.
But it will put you in
the right direction
on the right path.
Finally, localize
your marketplace
metadata as I just mentioned.
This, by itself, significantly
improves findability of your
app on marketplace, specifically
the Chrome web
store as well as Google
Play as well.
That brings us to the conclusion
of our talk.
Most of the stuff that we have
referenced here, you can--
reference what we have covered
here, you can essentially find
on developer.google
.com/international.
As the [? GTTA ?]
comes out, you will essentially
find the updates here.
So again, it's
developers.google.com.
That's pretty much it.
We are out of time
for questions.
Thank you.